this is one thing that I'm curious about
whenever I used to see a teacher or
especially a principal outside school it
was weird it was very strange because I
didn't think they could exist outside of
the reality of school and so have you
had that experience where a parent or
kids have seen you out in the world and
it's weird yeah I don't live in the town
that I work in for that very reason I
feel like there's it's a healthy buffer
or I can still live my life so you live
over seven hours away yes I commute
that's why I listen to your podcast a
whole bunch you live in you live in you
live in Florida and you own a seaplane
and you go to Dallas that's incredible
uh so so you live far away does it ever
happen though that you still see
somebody yeah so every once in a while I
will still still see people I mean like
I I live close to Dallas and so I when
we go to dinner go do something go out
like I go towards the Dallas just so I
can avoid that but you know I still will
always see a kid I learned my lesson my
very first year that I was a teacher and
coach and the town that I taught in
um it's huge and they have this
beautiful mall it's beautiful and I was
new to the area and I was like well
let's go and I needed um underwear and I
went to a place to buy underwear that
everybody knows by the look of their bag
you know where you've been which which
store which store is this because I know
them all oh god oh okay uh Victoria's
Secret okay yeah you know them all I've
been to every Victoria's Secrets Outlet
oh that's one of my claims to fame I
just hang around finaster and then I get
asked to leave now they have my picture
up but anyway so what happened you went
to a Victoria's Secret yeah and like
they have a good sale it's like five for
35 so I go there and I walk out can I
ask you so quickly Jenna did you buy
some unmentionable stop stop stop stop
stop I love it when people refer to them
as unmentionables Oh I thought you were
okay I mentioned balls sorry I had I
cocaine I had just before we did that
was I didn't know what that was you were
snorting it was delicious I think it was
new I thought it was an analgesic I
shouldn't have said this was delicious
cocaine because that ruins it who says
this is delicious no one says that
that's so stupid I'm sorry so Jenna back
to your story you go
you go to Victoria's Secrets you
purchase a few let's just call them
unmentionables and you're walking out
yeah and I walk out and I hear uh coach
Posey coach Posey and I was like that
was my maiden name and I was like oh my
God and I turn around and it's a boy a
little sixth grader that I had in class
and his dad and they're like hey how can
do it but you can just see like the
dad's gays like honed in on the Pink
Pack yeah getting you see the kids I
wander down there after it got past the
shock of seeing you know your teacher in
public so I no longer shop in the town I
teach you were driven out of you were
pretty much driven out of town you know
basically because of that embarrassing
moment what I do
is I carry everything in a Victoria's
Secrets bag so people get used to it
so that's a good strategy yeah I just
instead of a briefcase I have a
Victoria's Secrets bag and then when I
do go to Victoria's Secrets right I'm
not embarrassed because people say
anytime people stop me I reach into my
Victoria's Secrets bag it's got like you
know Coors Light in there or sometimes I
just Miller Light you mean Miller Lite
because they you're right it's got
Miller Lite in there because they are
advertisers
um and uh or it's got my books a book
I'm reading or it's got some papers or
sometimes I'll just uh scoop uh you know
turkey chili in there and I carry that
around but then occasionally when I buy
my wife some unmentionables
at uh Victoria's Secret no one knows
yeah sometimes I forget to take the
chili out first and they're just covered
in Turkey oh God yeah but that's one of
my Kinks
[Music]
Jenna did I ruin your day by talking to
you uh no no I hear crazier things every
day that's not possible that is not she
works with middle schoolers by the way I
think I I think I've got them beat I
think I'm the least mature person you've
spoken to in years and you're a middle
school principal
I I mean turkey chili in a Victoria
Secret bag with not on my bingo card for
today